[Music]
welcome to Tech news briefing it's
Tuesday May 16th I'm Zoe Thomas for The
Wall Street Journal
last week we learned Linda yaccarino a
veteran advertising executive who
recently left NBC Universal would become
Twitter's next CEO according to
Twitter's owner and current CEO Elon
Musk she'll focus on the business
operations while he focuses on the
product and Tech side that division of
labor is not something new to musk he
employs it at his other company SpaceX
with me to talk about how that
managerial structure works and whether a
social media company can mirror that
approach is our Aerospace reporter Micah
maidenberg Micah can you briefly
describe how spacex's run what is musk's
role and what do other Executives do so
from the very top of the meningerial
ranks of SpaceX you have Elon Musk of
course who founded the company more than
20 years ago and Gwen Shotwell Miss
Shotwell is spacex's long-time president
and chief operations officer and as as
those titles might imply Shotwell is
focused on day-to-day operations
employee issues and customer
relationships that leaves Elon Musk more
free to do
engineering design you know get into
some of the technical nitty-gritty that
he's talked about in general as the
stuff that he really likes to to focus
on you know not just at SpaceX but other
companies that he owned or leave
now there's a lot of vice presidents and
other executive leaders like underneath
them that are handling more specific
programs at the company Rockets
satellites and so on but just at the
very top that split between Mr musk and
Miss Shotwell has been a really
important one over time for the company
I mean Mike is known for putting a lot
sure on his
teams to get big things done fast how
has Shotwell talked about working under
that pressure she said a big part of her
job is basically translating these
enormously ambitious goals that musk has
set out for SpaceX and translating them
turning them into reality basically
things that can be supported by
customers and that can work technically
Michelle was talked about how Elon Musk
has very aggressive timelines he wants
to push hard and fast she's talked about
how SpaceX doesn't always meet those
timelines but she says in general they
get the stuff that they set out to do
done
the aggressive approach to getting stuff
done Michelle said drives the company to
do stuff better to make stuff faster she
said that she doesn't necessarily think
that having more time and more money
will produce the best outcome for any
given technical program but rather that
pressure across various teams is like
what
has allowed SpaceX to sort of leap out
to a lead in a couple of uh the key
business divisions that it's set up over
the years what indication do we have
that musk is following that same
approach that he's used at SpaceX at 20
Twitter there's more than a few
indications that's going on one is just
simply the heightened kind of pressure
on employees you know obviously Twitter
is a much leaner company than it was
before Elon Musk purchased it the people
have left they've been laid off and the
folks that are there you know I'm sure
listeners will recall were expected to
take uh extremely hardcore approach to
you know how they approach their jobs
and that's not dissimilar again to how
SpaceX is sort of hired built a team of
Engineers and other technical folks and
other support personnel and so on and
expected them to build quickly and be
extremely dedicated to what they're
supposed to do so that's one another one
is the stock based compensation approach
that for years SpaceX has used sort of
stock grants to help pay employees and
Twitter is doing the same of course
they're both private companies so it
creates some different Dynamics than
what then how you use shares to pay
employees like at a publicly traded
company and third maybe the last thing
to mention is just this broader sort of
ethos if you will of trying to do things
quickly even at the risk of failure
SpaceX is really well known across the
space industry for being willing to bend
some metal to destroy Hardware
listeners of course remember about a
month ago April 20th the company blasted
off a Starship rocket for the first time
and it flew for about four minutes
before it was destroyed and you know the
company in mosca said look we got data
from that flight we got information
and the next one will be better are
there any drawbacks to that approach or
any reason why it might not work for a
social media company the way it works
for a space company it might actually be
in some ways easier to do this at
Twitter because you're making changes to
a software platform that users
experience whereas at SpaceX you might
be spending weeks and months developing
building Rockets bending metal dealing
with hazardous Fuel propellants and
other sort of chemicals and building
poured and concrete for launch pads so
there's a lot of like physical
infrastructure and changes that happen
in in the real world you know to like uh
blast off a rocket and you lose a lot of
that work Twitter is about to get a new
CEO oh I overlaps in in style or
approach that we know about between
yakarino and Shotwell that might be
important for working with musk both
Miss yakarino and Michelle will have
these reputations of being really tough
really good at their jobs but pretty
congenial too that makes sense if you
think about it because both are dealing
with customers of all kinds and you've
gotta both build relationships with
customers and of course you're
bargaining with them too over like terms
of various deals that's a bit of a
contrast with Mr musk who has this very
big megaphone on Twitter he has a lot of
followers there and chimes in on a lot
of different topics he certainly has
gained some notoriety for his
temperamental at times like manner all
right that was our Aerospace reporter
Micah maidenberg
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more Tech stories head over
to our website wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal thanks for
listening
[Music]